stay tuned later this month when Richard
and Sal will be competing in a decathlon
we want the Richard and South to dock
their penises together for the opening
ceremony and Sal was reluctant to do it
for some reason we finally found
something Sal didn't want to do for
October and Richard was gaming yeah so
the head of my penis my dick lips would
be kissing his dick lips essentially you
know right and my foreskin would roll
over the head of his penis and what's
your problem with it it's just I don't
want my penis touching his penis it's
too intimate you know you're afraid it's
almost like it hard you're afraid that's
what I'm thinking
that's it
I won't get a boner if I do that I bet
you would I won't
look at him that nervous laughs
I'm not gonna I'm turning red because
the thought of me getting a boner
sharing my penis with this canned ham is
ridiculous but you know what it reminds
me of boys remember uh I used to go down
to Chinatown they had those finger traps
that's right yeah you know so so really
the idea of your [ __ ] becoming one big
long [ __ ] seems to me to be a good uh
opening Salvo for the bonding yeah uh
but uh I don't know I I saw your dead
set against it huh that one I don't want
to do and there are a few things Richard
doesn't want to do either I wanted to do
a Cova test where I twist the uh my
pouch my foreskin into a Q-tip and shove
it up Richard's nostrils he won't do
that why not why not I'd probably end up
doing it I don't know uh probably at the
time it sounded weird but now this stuff
says that I think I'm up for it we got
some exciting events coming up let's
tell everyone that you guys will be uh
part of the decathlon also medicated
Pete's going to make a special event
he's going to sing he's going to sing
into his own penis using his penis as a
microphone and the decathlon that these
two guys are going to be involved in
you're going to have some dick fishing
yep tai kwon dong and penis golf for the
first time ever for October
um I met you Poss could you possibly
have more information on this the plan
is Sal is going to have a magnet on his
penis and there's going to be a plastic
fish sticking out of Richard's ass crack
that he needs to bend down and use his
penis to uh fish out that way yeah well
they've improved the game because we
were going to do it before uh like not
in person so now I guess we'll do it in
person we can uh well Monday we have an
hour of research and development planned
for these games to make sure that they
all go by the way this might be a good
opportunity to say any young
broadcasters who are looking for work
should always think about the mecca
Howard Stern Show where we research and
practice these kinds of bits uh it's
there's no work nothing left a chance
right it's not as easy
competition the golf work basically
there's going to be a a plastic golf
club that is attached to one of the boys
penises the other person will sit on the
floor with a sort of bell attached to
their scrotum and the person will try to
hit the bell with the golf club
um it has made as few Strokes as
possible can I make a suggestion don't
you think uh like Richard's [ __ ]
again should be the hole in one and then
um and then the then when Sal swings uh
his golf club he should try to get the
golf ball in Richard's ass I'll add that
to the research and development agenda
so we can try both the [ __ ] and the
ball I could lay on my back and we put a
table that like levels with my [ __ ]
so the ball goes like right in my
[ __ ] yeah
all these kind of things in my mind I
mean the guy's a genius that's why we
call him tiger Woody but uh looking
forward to the golf and all the other
dick cathlon events for our big fifth
anniversary of cocktober got 31 days of
October I got my hand on your [ __ ] hair
dick and balls and it's over while we're
beginning